bonjour et merci de train avec nous sur
rt france est ce que ces révélations si
elles étaient avérées vous surprennent
non il ne surprenne absolument pas
puisque la france est était un des rares
pays européens à ne pas s'être doté du
logiciel pegasus donc que les
tractations ont eu lieu en amont pour se
doter de ce logiciel de surveillance ne
n'est pas du tout surprenant bon bien
évidemment c'est quelque chose de
hautement diplomatique on est avec
israël on est là en l'occurrence aussi
avec avec le maroc donc on
kim usa qui nous à surveiller donc on
est on est vraiment dans des eaux
extrêmement extrêmement on va dire
marécageuse et il est temps que
aujourd'hui un moratoire puisse être
comme le nul à préconiser instauré sur
l'utilisation et la mise en place de ce
type de dispositif rappelle notamment
qui était visé par un logiciel à pégase
et c'est pourquoi pourquoi un tel
scandale c'est alors qu'asus c'est un
donc un logiciel de surveillance qui est
mis à la disposition des tas a priori un
exclusivement d'état donc l'allemagne le
mexique plein plein plein de pays comme
ça se sont dotés de ceux de là donc ça
c'était les sauts qu'il a trahi les
haines qu'il acquit l'avenir qu'il a
développé et mis en place et donc il y
avait un essai de protocole d'accord qui
était établie avec les autorités
israéliennes pour l'utilisation de ces
de ceux de ce dispositif est donc on
pouvait estiot n'est tout simplement pas
on va dire n'importe qui puisqu'il était
extrêmement performant et il avait
surtout cette particularité de ne pas
pouvoir et de déceler par des
dispositifs anti entier espionnage l'or
depuis il ya eu un petit peu de un petit
peu de remue-ménage et donc on a en a
beaucoup plus de possibilités d'avoir
une une surveillance de ce type de deux
logiciels mais dont on a eu des
politiques des avocats des militants de
droits de l'homme des ong enfin pour
toutes sortes de personnes y compris
dans dans le gouvernement français
manifestement et des personnes haut
placées en france qui ont été espionné
pendant plusieurs heures plusieurs mois
sinon sinon davantage qu'est ce que cela
révèle finale c'est un jeu de dupe tout
le monde pousse des cris d'orfraie quand
le quand le scandale éclate mais
finalement tout le monde c'est spécial
tout le monde surveille tout le monde
bien évidemment bon ça c'est vieux comme
comme la nuit des temps il ya toujours
eu des services de renseignements du
lion qui sont intervenus pour pour
espionner les les amis de l'autre côté
de la frontière où plus loin aujourd'hui
les moyens les moyens technologiques
sont tels qu'on peut on peut arriver à
faire des miracles par rapport à truc
type de dispositif et il serait
peut-être intéressant aujourd'hui il
n'ya plus lu ment rien qu'à ma
connaissance qu'il soit sorti qu'une
commission parlementaire puisse être
s'être mises en place pour savoir un
petit peu dans quelles conditions la
france a et a été amené à intervenir par
rapport aux autorités israéliennes pour
acquérir ce logiciel comment se les
tractations ont capoté et est-ce que
c'est véritablement la révélation par
l'article ou la licité qui a qui a
simplement stoppé ou bon on a eu peur
d'être des prix le la main dans le pot
de confiture donc on et voilà je pense
qu'israël serait il serait bien que les
parlementaires puissent se saisir de la
question par exemple pour savoir
pourquoi la france qui se targue de
toutes les vertus sont l'oeuvre
l'occurrence finalement à fait comme les
petits copains oui parce que vous faites
référence d'imaginaire au chef de la
diplomatie française jean yves le drian
qui démontait que la france ait voulu
acquérir le logiciel sa parole est mise
en question désormais est
celle de la diplomatie donc on va dire
que le discours de monsieur le drian et
est bien évidemment extrêmement formaté
aujourd'hui d'après d'après ce qu'on en
sait bon puisque c'est surtout le maroc
qui manifestement a eu des velléités
surveillance par rapport à nous on veut
pas trop taper sur le maroc et c'est
plutôt avec les israéliens que les
négociations se font de manière à ce que
à l'avenir les par exemple des numéros
de téléphone avec un préfixe 30 fois
donc la france puisse être totalement
exclue de la surveillance de le pegasus
comme les américains l'ont négocié avec
l'israélien également merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation sur
air france qui rêve à la chapelle que
vous êtes avocat spécialiste des numéros